[Music]
dr dan anxiously paced in his cell it
was the only way he'd been able to
occupy himself for the past six months
saved for pouring through files and when
he was lucky being able to oversee
another failed termination attempt he
only stopped pacing gwen for a brief and
horrible moment he realized that monster
was probably doing the exact same thing
in its big metal cube at this very
moment that horrible creature that he'd
thrown away his life for a futile shot
at killing perhaps the whole thing had
been a fool's errand after all he was
formerly a researcher under the employee
of the scp foundation secure contain
protect they had truly sadistic beasts
like scp-106
the nightmarish old man and scp-352
baba yaga in containment cells and there
was no plans to terminate either of them
they weren't the global occult coalition
for 343's sake why did dr dan even want
to terminate
scp-096 in the first place he tried to
explain it to them again and again but
his pleas had fallen on deaf ears in his
mind the impetus for destroying the shy
guy was terrifyingly clear it was a
monster that killed anyone or anything
that looked at its face even a
photograph of it even a tiny collection
of pixels when its rage state was
induced it seemed that nothing would
stop it it would have an intuitive
psychic link to its victim charge at
them at breakneck speed and only find it
zen again once all of them were dead and
if a picture of scp-096 was leaked onto
the internet it would cause a chain
reaction that triggered an xk class and
the world scenario there were plenty of
creatures and entities that the
foundation knew about that could
theoretically bring about the apocalypse
but to him 096 was the most realistic it
preyed upon the inherent curiosity and
thirst for knowledge seated in every
human heart the same drive to simply
know that led to the creation of the scp
foundation would be humanity's doom in
the face of an
scp-096 outbreak and if such a thing
happened the foundation would need to
break the masquerade of secrecy to have
any hope of saving humanity in his many
feverish nightmares dr dan had seen it
all so clearly the first photographs of
scp-096's face would be leaked online
perhaps a few hundred people across the
globe would look in disparate enough
locations that it would be almost
impossible for the foundation to detect
and save all of them as
scp-096 went on its bloody rampage of
course as the image proliferated as
images on the internet often do
the purview of 096's violence would only
grow people across the nation would
start to take notice and soon after that
across the world mysterious creature
causing mass casualties would be the
headline on every news desk because why
would anybody want to talk about
anything else perhaps some foolish
reporters would take video footage of
the creature everyone has a phone these
days with high definition cameras
pictures would be taken and posted more
and more of it would flood the internet
too many simultaneous moles for even the
scp foundation to whack the news would
spread panic and hysteria would spread
people wouldn't even know what's
triggering all this horror if the
foundation didn't go public and tell
them that it was the pictures that was
killing everyone and by then wouldn't it
already be too late the antidote to fear
is knowledge it's why when anything goes
wrong we're refreshing timelines and
feeds and news websites for any kind of
information and if you were told an
unstoppable monster was killing scores
of people and might be coming to a
neighborhood near you sometime soon
wouldn't you want a good look at it
wouldn't you want to know your enemy
having no idea that the mere act of
knowing was what sealed your horrible
fate by dr dan's bleak estimations if
only several million people died as a
result of this kind of scenario it could
be considered a positive outcome he'd
seen it all but no matter how many times
he tried to articulate this to his
superiors he wasn't listened to they
didn't take him or the threat that
scp-097 posed seriously every time he
warned of the apocalyptic potential of
scp-096
he was simply told to get back to
working on those goggles it was why he
needed to give those naysayers a
demonstration it was why a certain
photograph needed to show up in the home
of a certain mountaineer it's why all
those people had to die there was no
other way the deaths of the civilians
and the researchers and the mobile task
force members were of course regrettable
but it was the only way to prevent the
deaths of so many more they gave him
what he wanted permission to put this
gangly time bomb in the ground even if
the beast's death was inextricably tied
to his own execution at the hands of the
very employers who authorized him the
world was full of funny little ironies
like that another one is that even
though dr dan now had the authorization
and funding to terminate scp-096
he was discovering that he lacked
another important factor the capability
they tried incinerating it exposing it
to massive amounts of radiation exposing
it to an insane degree of kinetic trauma
the equivalent of being hit by an
out-of-control bullet train they tested
every kind of experimental off the books
weaponry that they had access to through
various research projects proton blasts
lasers high intensity energy beams
nothing even when they fried off every
scrap of flesh on the monster's body its
unbreakable skeleton still remained and
in what seemed like no time at all it'd
be back in action its very existence
seemed to mock him the guard opened his
cell door staring disdainfully at the
disgraced researcher that same guard had
slammed his head against a wall a month
earlier one of his friends had
apparently been killed in the legendary
096 containment breach that set this
whole sword thing in motion up an atom
scumbag he said in the gruff surly voice
training a handgun on the doctor he knew
wouldn't fight back they need you in
test chamber six
dr dan allowed himself a small grin
imperceptible to the guard who clearly
hated his guts they'd approved his 096
versus 682 cross test marvelous how
marvelous to all the others it would
seem like just one more entry in a long
line of 682 cross tests he thought it
darkly funny in his eyes the foundation
had no hope of ever killing
scp-682 its defining quality was being
impossible to kill and it didn't present
nearly the threat to the entire world
that 096 posed their futile attempts to
murder the lizard were little more than
a money sink to justify the site's
exorbitant funding but perhaps he could
turn this to his benefit maybe
scp-682 would hold the secret to
actually killing off his nemesis within
30 hours dr dan had his disappointing
answer both anomalies had undeniably
done a real number on each other and dr
dan did take a kind of sick amusement in
the mental trauma that scp-680 had
induced in zero nine sex but ultimately
it was all for nothing 682 had skin 096
alive and melted off its flesh with acid
but once again that indestructible
skeleton stood firm this had been the
27th termination attempt since the
incident the 27th failed termination
attempt dr dan mentally corrected
himself 096's skeleton kept defeating
them even their most ardent attempts to
penetrate the bones and destroy the
creature within had failed during a
previous attempt they tried to access
the brain by putting a diamond hard
drill into its eye sockets of course it
was the drill that actually broke much
to dr dan's seemingly tireless
frustration needless to say in the
debriefing interview with dr carver a
researcher who once would have
considered him a colleague he wasn't in
high spirits if he managed to kill this
thing then he would always be the hero
who made a terrible sacrifice in order
to save many more lives if he didn't
kill 096 he was little more than the
monster who murdered all those innocent
people for nothing
though you'd never hear him say it out
loud if it wasn't for that damnable
indestructible skeleton this monster
would be long dead already if only there
was some way to break the creature's
bones that's when it hit him
scp-173 the sculpture a site-19 icon
often overlooked because of its more
silent but deadly style but undeniably
one of the most frightening and
dangerous anomalies out there it had
racked up a truly shocking body count
since it was first interred at site 19
in 1993 one broken neck at a time and
it's one of the few creatures out there
that even the hard to destroy reptile
himself is utterly terrified of perhaps
a monster that practically has a phd in
breaking bones would be the ideal
candidate to vandalize the shy guy's
vertebrae once his proposal was greenlit
for initial testing dr dan arranged for
the shy guy with a bag over his head of
course to be brought into a testing
chamber with the ever stoic
scp-173 when all of the researchers and
guards were safely outside all it took
was a single blink to make all of dr
dan's darkest dreams come true in the
nanoseconds his eyes were closed he
heard the most beautiful sounds in the
world a loud fleshy crunch and a pained
howl from 096. he opened his eyes to an
equally wondrous sight 096 doubled over
at an unnatural angle its spine snapped
between the 4th and 5th vertebrae spinal
fluid leaking down the creature's flank
that freaky little sculpture had done it
it had actually damaged the integrity of
the shy guy's skeleton it was at that
moment that dr dan knew he could kill
this thing admittedly there was a
containment breach shortly after that
when the bag slipped off of 096's head
and it charged through the nearby steel
wall killing multiple people before
being subdued and recontained but when
it comes to projects involving dr dan a
mere handful of innocent people being
killed
sits comfortably within the acceptable
margin of error a day later dr dan was
standing before a crowded boardroom with
agents researchers and even a few
members of the o5 council in attendance
he explained his findings to them and
the fact that even more importantly they
may have a way to bring the wretched
existence of 096 to an absolute halt his
plans were approved not long after he
was putting them into motion dr dan was
surrounded by researchers and heavily
armed guards as 173 was escorted into
the test chamber with a forklift 096 was
there still bagged off to the side was a
giant tub of hydrofluoric acid connected
to a hose and injector attachment if
this didn't work nothing would everyone
stood back in a safe zone as 173 was
released to do its thing crunch just
like the previous time 096's spine had
been successfully snapped spinal fluid
dribbled down its skin everyone had
rushed into the chamber one group kept
173 isolated with their stairs the other
headed by dr dan prepared the acid
injector and shoved it into the breech
in 096's spine as the acid was pumped by
the gallon into 096's bones the creature
let out the most horrifying whale it
kicked and bucked as more acid was
pumped in melting those indestructible
bones from within the creature even
began to vomit acid as it panicked
melting the bag off of its own head some
panicked and averted their gaze dr dan
didn't he stared directly at the
creature's face for the first time as it
melted in front of him with nothing
short of pure elation had he won had he
actually won the creature let out a
gurgling shriek and the guards opened
fire their bullets splattered into the
monsters melting flesh and bones as it
hollered and shrieked they didn't let up
firing up and down its body spraying it
with white hot lead it began to melt and
bubble away expanding into a great
gruesome puddle on the floor beneath
them
dr dan
laughed like a madman even as the guards
grabbed him and dragged him away from
the foul-smelling greasy mess bubbling
with chemical life he just kept laughing
even though he knew the death of 096
meant an equally swift death of his own
it didn't matter it had all been for
something the world was saved it was
over he'd finally
won now go check out scp-096
shy guy escape incident
096-1-a containment breach and
scp-096 look at a picture of shy guy in
space the shy guy questions and theories
for more on scp-096